[Music]
so you support Donald Trump I'm not
gonna yell I'm not gonna say you're
wrong I'm not going to talk about his
policies I'm not going to talk about his
promises I'm not going to talk about
whether he's gonna cut your taxes or
raise them I'm not going to talk about
whether he's gonna make America great
again or crash it and burn it and unlike
what you probably think I'm not trying
to get the election overturned I'm not
trying to get Hillary Clinton into the
White House I'm not claiming the
Republican Party won't be there for at
least the next four years no this is
about him and you and the respect for
you I start with because you're watching
this you are thoughtful enough to have
gotten this far frankly I don't know if
I could watch your video so let's go in
on the assumption that you're smarter
than I am in which case you already know
what my point is going to be I don't
know who the political figure would be
if our places were reversed I guess the
time I ever got the closest to the
position you are in was with John
Edwards who had a problem and see it and
while he was not my first choice I would
have supported him for president he had
what I thought was a great humane set of
policies and he had a wife who was so
smart and had been through so much in
life that she probably should have been
the candidate instead of him and then it
turned out John Edwards was a con man
who had not only fooled me he had also
fooled her too if Edwards wasn't my
version of this it would have to be
Anthony Weiner I used to have him on my
TV show a lot he gaves straightforward
damn the torpedoes kinds of answers you
never get from politicians he disliked
the same Republicans I disliked and he
hated the same Democrats I hated and
even after he crashed and burned the
first time and then he tried to run for
mayor of New York I thought well he has
forgotten that problem fixed and he
might be really good mayor and then it
happened again in fact it had barely
stopped and the next time I saw him a
year ago I literally was afraid to shake
his hand in case a somebody took a
picture of it for be in case whatever he
had it was catching so I have not been
where you are right now but close and
you are in a terrible position a man
whose opinions you agree
with has been elected president and is
about to be sworn in and yet I'm pretty
sure you know the problem here you were
smart and generally speaking the only
person who can fool you is you you're
smart enough to recognize something I
saw when I first met this man 33 years
ago and that is this there is something
really really wrong with him who does
this on Christmas Eve his tweet was a
plug for a documentary a documentary
about him not even a new documentary a
repeat who does this on Christmas Eve
his Christmas greeting on Twitter was
just a photo of himself not the family
not the wife not the kids not even the
vice president not Santa
not Jesus just him who does this
two days later meaning 49 days after the
election
the election is still all he was
tweeting about President Obama
campaigned hard and personally in the
very important swing states and lost
what kind of man does this you win you
act like you've won before you don't
waste your energy on the guy who was
gone in a month anyway maybe maybe if
you're a good guy you're you're gracious
in victory you're a good winner at least
during the holidays happy New Year to
all including to my many enemies and
those who have fought me and lost so
badly they just don't know what to do
love would you write that would you
write that when you got votes from fewer
people than the other candidate did
would you call everybody else your enemy
okay maybe just because when I
interviewed him when I was 25 and he
owned a football team and I came away
muttering to my producer what's wrong
with that guy maybe I'm still wrong
maybe there's nothing really dangerous
about a man who has to tell you how much
he won by again and again and again when
he actually didn't win by very much
maybe that doesn't matter maybe from
where you sit it's only about make
America great again in America first and
always defending this country because we
are right and we need to be loyal to our
great nation vitomir Putin said today
about Hillary and Dems in my opinion is
humiliating one must be able to lose
with dignity so true great move on delay
by V Putin I always knew he was very
smart who defends a Russian dictator
ahead of an American president any
American president or American
politician or half of the people in
America I mean when he was president as
much as I hated george w bush
I never took Vladimir Putin's side
against george w bush would you do that
maybe you would I said I wouldn't yell
I'm not going to to my mind it is
possible for you to agree with Donald
Trump and still be a good person I just
disagree with you but I don't think
you're my enemy
well let me run one last pair of tweets
past you and ask you if you think they
were written by a normal guy various
media outlets and pundits say that I
thought I was gonna lose the election
wrong it all came together in the last
week and I thought I felt I would win
big easily over the fabled 270 306 when
they canceled fireworks they knew and so
did I so those tweets are from last
Monday that means it had only been three
weeks he got up at one of those Victory
Tour stops this one was in West Allis
Wisconsin on December 13th and he said
he thought he was gonna lose the
election and he thought he was gonna
lose the election on the night of the
election quote I go and see my wife I
say baby I'll tell you what we're not
going to win tonight because the polls
have come out I always used to believe
in those exit polls I don't believe in
them anymore I said if we're gonna lose
I don't want a big ballroom there are a
lot of choices here are there I mean he
either lied in the tweets or at the tour
stop in Wisconsin or to his wife that
night or he forgot that he said it or
there's something wrong with him to
pretend that there isn't something wrong
with him you have to pretend really hard
and I know you can't say it I know you
don't want to believe it and I know you
won't believe this either but I wish it
were not true but we have elected a man
who is not all there
and that cannot end happily for anybody
his illness
and it is an illness is putting you at
risk and your family at risk and your
kids and my family and everybody we know
the ones we like and the ones we don't
don't say anything don't do anything I
don't even want you to admit anything to
anybody except to yourself but you know
that someday probably soon something bad
will happen and whatever he does will
make it worse and it will all be clear
that he's not healthy enough to be the
president and they will have to remove
him and by the way it will be the
Republicans who will have to remove him
either the vice president and the
Speaker of the House using the 25th
amendment or the Republican congressman
and the Republican senators impeaching
him because this isn't about what he
believes in this is about the fact that
he's not well
so all I'm asking all that this video
has been about is for you to just think
about it for when the time comes because
when the Republicans really need to
remove him as president they will need
to do it in a hurry and as a Republican
or as a conservative or as a Democrat or
as an American or whichever way you
describe yourself it will be a lot
easier and a lot safer for all of us if
you have prepared yourself and you help
them remove him because he is not well
thanks for listening